hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast phones have run a novel new
biomarker for assessment of kidney
function early prediction to identify
identification of acute kidney injury I
am Robert Castellanos of lab roads and
I'll be a moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
rats and sponsored by student tech Jen
effect develops innovative biomarkers
for diagnosis prediction and monitoring
of acute medical conditions such as
acute heart failure acute kidney injury
and circulatory shock in order to
support patient management and provide
guidance for treatment strategies
further marciano tech develops
biomarkers for prediction of health
risks except as obesity cardiovascular
diseases breast cancer in order to
support prevention strategies for more
information please visit see no sat-comm
we have a few of important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event we can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button /
left this is an educational webinar
unless offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on the sea but we located in the
bottom left hand corner of your web page
and follow the process of obtaining
their credits another way to interact in
today's webinar is by taking a few
moments and answering questions that are
being pushed out to you the audience
right now there will be another chance
to interact with these post questions at
the end of our presentation right before
an intersection I'd like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Alan nasal dr. Alan
legal graduated from the University of
Michigan Medical School received his
international medicine training and
Michael Reese Hospital in Chicago and
completed a cardiology fellowship at the
university California San Diego dr.
nasal is a professor of medicine at the
university of california san diego UCSD
he is the director of the coronary caved
and heart failure program at the VA San
Diego health care system in la jolla
california after mazal is an active on
the faculty at UCSD where he has won
numerous teaching awards he is destined
as the 10-year stint as associate editor
of the journal of the american college
cardiology he has considered one of the
world's experts on cardiac biomarkers
and has over 300 scientific publications
he has authored several groundbreaking
publications that have paved the way to
development of diagnostic tools for
patients with congestive heart failure
in particular he was the leading
investigator on studies that brought the
use of BNP into clinical practice I will
now hand it over to the doctors for his
presentation okay thank you very much
for that kind introduction and i am dr.
Ellen May's L and I'd like to thank each
of the attendees for taking a little bit
of time out of their day to listen to
what I have to say about this very
interesting biomarker pro and kefflin
and please ask questions at the end and
hopefully we'll have time to answer each
and every one so you know I'm going to
start out by just mentioning how
important it is to be able to diagnose
early kidney injury especially in
critically ill patients and this is an
unmet need and it's a big one aki acute
kidney injury is a frequent complication
about thirty percent of everybody in the
ICU fifty percent of people with
septic shock and in those patients where
you get a ki in septic shock there's a
mortality rate of fifty percent hence it
behooves us if we have any chance of
helping that patient to make the early
and accurate diagnosis here's just a
chart that depicts in the red they're
all hospitalizations and the blue bars
are the prevalence or incidence of
kidney injury or acute renal failure and
you can see that more and more kidney
injury is occurring in hospitalized
patients this slide demonstrates that
percentage of where these kidney
injuries occur and about half or a
little more than half occur right in the
hospital about thirty five percent in
primary care and about twelve or
thirteen percent during outpatient
procedures now when we talk about an
biomarker testing in general and i'll
use heart disease as an example to start
with because this can serve as a good
introduction to how to look at kidney
biomarkers in heart disease we would use
a biomarker for diagnosis or risk
stratification and screening and if we
are lucky to monitor and then to offer
therapeutic guidance in other words you
have a condition to see on the right
that has a certain outcome can we find a
path of physiologically relevant
biomarker that will lead us to an
intervention that can change that
outcome that's what we want to use
biomarkers for and in heart failure you
know it's fairly straightforward there
are three that I measure right now in my
heart failure patients that all have
relevant pathophysiologic mechanisms
whether they be mechanical stress
ischaemia volume overload fibrosis that
lead to disease activity all these
biomarkers can boob and be affected by
treatment and they're very important
surrogates that we can use and
as I've been speaking and going to the
Reno meetings I would ask well where are
the biomarkers for the kidney injury and
you know I point out to what we have had
say it acute myocardial infarction but
over the years if you compare we really
have not had anything except the serum
creatinine which is most of us know is
not an early marker the promise for
biomarkers or kidney injury would be
like the promise of the high sensitivity
troponin with a cardiologist we want a
nephrology troponin if you will to be
measured somewhere that will lead us to
early management and perhaps development
in new therapeutic strategies even if we
don't have any right now in part it is
because we haven't had an early signal
to treat early and I think once we have
that new therapeutic strategies will in
fact be studied and we will find some
good ones now let's just go over a few
important considerations for renal
assessment with biomarkers the protein
or hormones should be a reflection of
renal function and this renal function
should be real time not past renal
function like we would see with sift at
sea or creatinine it should be
analytically validated for accuracy and
precision in the clinical study the
results should be easily interpreted in
the study is your cutoff below which
you're safe above which you have risk
and does this test have clinical value
well you know you see these are a bunch
of the biomarkers that are either for
research or clinically available but
also the present day take a look at
creatinine look at the simple matrix the
inflammation the specificity and the
dynamic status and if you go down the
line study with creating we see there's
really at least an unmet need that we
still
need to fulfill and that's where pro and
Kevin comes in a new biomarker of renal
dysfunction now current effluent is new
but an kathlynn is not we all learned
about in Kaplan in med school because
it's a it's linked to many opioid
receptors but it was always almost
impossible to make the right s8 to study
it in real time there's we've learned
about the cns derived and kept lens
which are sort of the natural
painkillers and but the non CNS and
Catherine's are actually release mainly
by the kidney and then the heart as
Hector's believe but released by the
kidney and then the heart so renal and
then probably as I'm a heart failure dr.
cardio renal these ligands are the two
different opioid receptors and they're
very abundant in the kitty so we think
that proa kevin is a biomarker that is a
surrogate marker for a tefl and it's a
pro neural hormone it was invented by
the same group over initially at thermo
fisher but now its single tech that
invented other pro neural hormones that
are important part of our practice such
as procalcitonin this marker is special
and instead panic prone kefflin is a log
name so we call this pen a pen and
kevlin pen kid for the kidney this is a
great surrogate marker as i'm going to
show you it's inflammation independent
and that separates their apart from any
other blood marker that i know it also
because of the stimulation and the
interaction with opioid receptors it
indicates an actual need for kidney
stimulation and subsequent renal
excretion so it's very active marker
functionally so here
is what pen kid measures it's a stable
component of the precursor it is the you
can see it's a 119 to 159 pulled out of
there it's very stable versus the
unstable and careful and peptides so
stable this can easily be used for
routine clinical testing with a very
good essay and around the 99 percentile
you have coefficient of variations for
you have Precision's you ten ten percent
well one of the reasons i like it is
shown here in this slide first of all
i've looked at many biomarkers of kidney
injury and many may show some link to
injury but don't really correlate the
kidney dysfunction these two slides
taken from two different studies
demonstrates both a strong correlation
with serum creatinine and an inverse
correlation with estimated GFR I think
this is very very important now to show
you the renal specificity here how it's
corroborated with the pen kit essay and
this is from dr. Eng then excuse me
looking at over a thousand patients
after an mi and in this one table taken
from the manuscript it shows overall
peghead levels reflective renal status
better than anything and there's a
tenfold difference in concordance of GFR
versus other predictors of pancake pen
kid levels were the highest upon
presentation as and very likely a
reflection of the overall Korea renal
status and in fact the reclassification
index for those graded as low risk but
had ventral complication was 18 using
the pen kit so it's not giving you just
diagnostic but it's giving you
rate risk stratification right off the
bat now as a heart failure doctor this
is one of the reasons I'm really
interested in Penn k because if you look
in these two graphs and and and I'm
going to go back to this but we're going
to use a cut point here of a hundred
pyka mole per liter this appears to be
one you could take home to the bank you
can use this today in your clinical
practice this shows the prediction and
the diagnosis of AKI in people with
sepsis and hartford days before the
creatinine goes up but also even more
important for me is prediction on the
right box of recovery because in my
heart failure patients get kidney injury
that creating may take five or six days
to come down I need to keep them in a
hospital tools starts to come down if
the pen k drafts three days earlier
that's three days earlier I can send
them home so pen kid is really
predictive of the onset and the offset
of kidney injury so let's look at the
clinical validation of pen kid in
clinical populations here first of all
and you should understand this because
if you think this is the new kid on the
block and it needs more studies well
think again there are more studies
coming but right now it has broad
validation there has been 25 thousand
patients in 18 countries over 600 study
centers where this has already been
looked at I think this is more patients
i would guess then even was looked at
early on with d-type natriuretic peptide
measurements let's start with cardiac
surgery because we did this right at my
hospital as a matter of fact
I sent some of my young students who
wanted to get experience into the o.r at
five o'clock in the morning to consent
and collect samples and then get him
post-op to 6 12 24 48 we found that in
those patients who developed associated
aki that pen kid and was elevated within
six hours creatinine only after two days
this is clinically I think a very
important especially in the early
post-op setting which rise in pen kid
could certainly trigger close attention
to pulmonary wedge pressure readings to
what we do with fluids and I know tropes
and also nephrotoxic potential for
antibiotics contrast etc so that's
cabbage let's look at other critically
ill patients let's start in sepsis right
in the emergency department now this
took place in the hospital of my dear
friend and colleague one of the leaders
in biomarkers dr. de soma who looked at
a hundred patients consecutive patients
who came in the ed and they diagnosed
sepsis they were enrolled within 12
hours and had daily blood draws and then
they defined here aki by the rifle and
criteria so here these two figures will
demonstrate number one that pen kid is
independent from information and to
predicts aki severity and mortality
notice that pen kid levels are in the
normal range if you have no kidney
injury or if you are just at risk risk
as the are for rifle you look at almost
any other biomarker in the blood and in
sepsis which has to do with inflammation
those levels will be high with no risk
or in the our group so this alone sense
pitched it sets pen kid levels apart
they are high when you have kidney
injury and the more you have the higher
they are in these septic patients if you
don't have it it's not up it's not
reflected by inflammation on the right
side you can see survivors and those
that are dead within seven days versus
pen kid levels again looking at that cut
point maybe a magic cut point of 100
pyka mole per liter admission 10k can
predict mortality but admission pancake
pink kid levels is not the only story
pen kid is a highly dynamic biomarker
this is why I like it I want a biomarker
that will tell me they're at risk tell
me they have injury and I can do
something and then see what happens and
I know if it gets better they're going
to get better and if it doesn't why I
better try something else here's for
patient patient one the whole
hospitalization is higher than the
normal range and died patient to at very
high levels 65 600 but toward the end of
the hospitalization it went down they
survived patient 3 started in the normal
range and but within several hours 12
went up and up and up and they died
patient for throughout the whole septa
course stayed low and they die any they
live so stay low they lived high you die
now this next slide will show that as
you measure serial pen kid levels you
can actually see the change in risk of
mortality by indicating kidney function
on the left side you can see the
survival rate and the time at a cut off
of a hundred based on whether you had Bo
Kincaid peg kid or
pen kit now if you look at the subgroup
that at high pen kit and then measured
it four days later if it was still high
fifty percent die if that pen kid went
to below a hundred they all survived
this is very important and I think if
you're a physician you can see right now
how this could help you even if we don't
know what to treat with although I have
some ideas we know by risk
stratification that they are now in a
low-risk group maybe they can go out of
the ICU to a step-down unit there's a
whole host of interventions we could
think about the therapeutic goal in
other words and sepsis is to try to
normalize the pen kid levels this slide
demonstrates that if they're normal you
are alive and if they're not you have a
good likelihood of dying do we know all
the treatments that can lower pain kid
no we don't but as they said in that
famous movie Field of Dreams build the
field and they will come find an early
marker that's associated with diagnosis
so you can get therapy started and
therapeutic companies will jump to the
table with interventions targeting pen
kid levels here's another sepsis study
and again this is 42 consecutive ICU
patients with major surgery and signs of
sepsis median age of 76 days in the ICU
18 days in the hospital and this is
renal dysfunction with acute decrease in
urinary output for at least two hours
despite fluid resuscitation and again
renal dysfunction and penn kid levels
you can see that when there's no renal
dysfunction penn kid is in that normal
range and it's quite high if there is a
sense that
there there are a multitude of studies
here these some of these have been
presented in small papers and abstracts
but the believe me the literature is
about to be inundated with these large
studies take this one out of France the
Frog I see you study over 2,000 patients
in the ICU sepsis and that sepsis and
this it was an observational study in an
ICU patients who either required
mechanical ventilation or vasopressors
or I know toaster over 24 hours during
their stay you can see the demographics
on the left side these are sick patient
on the right side you can see aki
severity by the rifle criteria pen kid
levels once again the pen kid levels are
not elevated until you get injury other
biomarkers of kidney injury do not have
this specificity when inflammation is
present and in sepsis there's almost
always inflammation so very few
biomarkers will be good to use in this
setting pen kid is one that can be used
right now here's another study you've
probably heard of this study it's quite
famous the abstract for the peghead just
been presented the paper is being
formatted this is the alveo study of
albumin giving in sepsis study and this
is an analysis substudy analysis once
again pen kid and was diagnostic for aki
and also predicted both the need for
renal replacement therapy as well as
90-day mortality so sepsis sepsis sepsis
it's there this is filling an unmet need
right now but as a cardiologist of
course I am interested in other types of
cardiac diseases
here's one by dr. and his group
published and Jack just in 2014 and the
prognosis of pent kid as a kidney
dysfunction marker can actually predict
mortality in acute myocardial infarction
above and below the median levels if you
look at penn kid and the two-year mace
prediction you can see the hazard ratio
univariate was 15 and a half the
multivariate of paint kid was five and a
half time five and a half fold risk it
beat the other biomarkers in this and
look at mt pro wasn't even significant
in a multivariate analysis and i think
this is because entity pro is so tied up
with clearance issues but this is one in
acute myocardial infarction that is
excellent at mace prediction also if you
look at long-term mortality and this is
the pink kid divided into three turtles
you can see the 99 percentile normal
here was about 80 but turtle 12 is in
our sweet spot of 82 129 enter tau 3 you
can see a marked correlation an event
free survival and those pent kid levels
so if you really look at the summary of
10 kid and the medical utility here is
one way to look at it if your pen kid on
the on the top there if it's elevated
and your serum creatinine is high you
have a ki if it's elevated but your
creatinine is still low you have a high
risk of a ki
that means you would certainly want to
monitor this and that means that perhaps
for me in the setting of heart failure
I'm going to be worried I'm going to be
worried in a heart failure patient that
looks pretty good that creatinine is
pretty okay but the pen kid is over a
hundred am I really going to send them
for contrast CT am I really going to
start them back on their ace inhibitor
right away am I really going to give
them high dose of a diuretic early in
the emergency room and the bottom of
this shows what a low pen kid means low
less than 100 does it mean that if it's
low but the creatinine so high that the
patient is recovering or if the
creatinine is low they have no aki now i
am a biomarker guy and i actually love
the negative predictive value of
biomarkers they're usually even better
than the positive predictive value catch
as a high sense troponin can rule out
acute myocardial infarction and a
hundred percent of people within two
hours a B and T of under a hundred can
rule out acute heart failure in ninety
to ninety-five percent of patient if
you're in the emergency room say with
heart failure which is what top you know
I like but even in sepsis and your pen
kid is low in your [ __ ] you are good
to go you're not worried about what you
start medicinewise this is important on
the other hand in heart failure thirty
percent of people get kidney injury in
the hospital most of this is somewhat
iatrogenic from all the diuretics we
give the ACE inhibitors and eldo
blockade etc but once they get kidney
injury and you have heart failures it
can take so long to come back we must
keep a patient in the hospital till that
creatinine comes down because we don't
know if it doesn't come down it
means it could have a chance to go up
which means you could send them home and
they could come in dead from
hyperkalemic cardiac arrest but when I
am able to use pen kid it will be very
likely that as I follow this patient
recovery I will see that pink kid drop
two to three days before the granting
drops and I can probably send them home
yes I will bring them back to double
check but I can probably send them home
and I would say to the family that I
think your husband is out of the woods
now the early marker of injury is
improving so some conclusions from our
evidence-based discussion today first
pen kid is a reliable surrogate plasmic
marker fur and kefflin which has been
around a long time expressed all over
the kidney and the heart but we could
never measure 10 kid has been clinically
validated in thousands of critically ill
patients more patients I would suggest
that B and P or possibly even troponin
before they were approved there is
definitely clinical utility of pen kit
because if you can predict and then
diagnose acute kidney injury diseases
like sepsis and heart failure there's a
lot you can do if you can monitor acute
injury for early recognition of
normalization that's a lot you can do
and that can you can reclassify that
patient down to a lower risk at them
home earlier at least out of a busy
expensive I see you a very important
takeaway point here lady at ladies and
gentlemen this pen kid is not affected
by systemic inflammation every other
blood biomarker that I can tell it's
been studied that rises early Also Rises
because of inflammation this does not so
in sepsis bingo
heart failure sometimes has inflammation
as well also other real-life variations
that have been looked at in these 20,000
people we have not seen pen k affected
other comorbidities age sex other
real-life variations maybe we'll find
some but we haven't really seen many yet
and finally if you want to bring a
biomarker out into clinical practice and
lord knows we have made many mistakes in
other kidney markers such as angle that
we have brought out in practice with
without reliable cut points for heart
failure for sepsis etc causing mass
confusion sometimes disbelief and then
finally abandonment as far as we can
tell these 20,000 patients you can put
that stamp of 100 pike a mole per liter
for all clinical settings and to
conclude I want to step back a little
bit and talk about how i use biomarkers
as as a clinician this is very important
it's a balancing act it really is the
merging of science of medicine the
guidelines the data but also merging
with the art of being a doctor now we go
back a second if I invite you to my
house and by the way just a plug april
seven we have a our famous biomarker
meeting in San Diego of which for years
we've been talking about this biomarker
and I and I say that because for faculty
etc that come over or friends what we
have a BBQ by the ocean at my place in
San Diego it's lovely place and if you
were coming and i would say what would
you like me to barbecue for you you have
a choice of chicken or steak well you
would be wise to
is steak and the reason is there are
more ways to grill chicken than steak I
mean grilled steak too chicken look at
this for steak and chicken it's
Salmonella or it's you can bounce it
like a rubber ball and it the analogy is
with biomarkers padding biomarkers
around ladies and gentlemen trust me
it's more like grilling steak than
chicken it gives you more opportunities
I told you all the opportunities that
you can see in sepsis in heart failure
some of these need to be tested in
randomized studies and some probably
don't some don't necessarily need to be
the guidelines but it makes clinical
sense why would you start keeping ace
inhibitor going if you saw a high risk
of a heart failure patient who needed a
lot of diuretics come in with volume
overload and a high pensionable need a
guideline study for that you need some
brains and that's why I sort of leave
with this a biomarker can make a bad
doctor worse but will make a good actor
better what do I mean you don't use a
biomarker by itself you use it secondary
to your clinical judgment here's the
stupid doctor here's an ER doctor in a
hospital in Boston reading at New York
Times probably hungover on a Sunday
morning feet up on the table the intern
comes and says dr. so-and-so I have a
patient of the high troponin and chest
pain and the doctor looks up and says
well is it a stemming well no and he
doesn't go see the patient doesn't read
the EKG but it says cardiology to see
patients with elevated troponin this is
a bad doctor ladies and gentlemen we
know the specificity issues here you
need to see the patient there
no substitute in medicine for hands-on
open-ended history and physical exam
demonstrating compassion and empathy so
that you can make the correct clinical
diagnosis and then you put together the
treatment plan and that biomarker helps
with the diagnosis the risk
stratification and yes ladies and Jim I
think it will help the treatment plants
because at the end of the day we as
physicians or healers you as even lab
people here are healers you help us get
these tests out there and this is what
we want to do we all have the brains we
went to medical school to nursing school
of business school whatever but what
separates out people who use biomarkers
it can't be lazy you have to fit it
together with everything else but when
we do ladies and gentlemen I can
guarantee you and at the end of the day
the good history and the physical and
then adding the biomarker is like pen
kid will lead to better care for our
patients I'll stop there thank you so
much for your attention and I'll turn it
over to the moderator for questions
thank you so very much doctor for your
outstanding presentation and thank you
so much for the audience for your
continuing used as the submission of
questions if you're just joining us
today here you aren't able to submit
questions by selecting the green Q&A
button I the lower left hand corner of
the presentation window we're going to
be actually sending out another poll
right now to you that is going to be
pushed out here and then you would if
you would mind taking a moment to
actually go ahead and answer those poll
questions for us today so doctor we do
have a couple of questions here that
have been coming in here the question
number one is it a rule for Penn kid in
cdk diagnosis monitoring and treatment
well that's that's a let me make sure
I'm not a mute ok I think that's an
excellent question it looks as if in
some early data that there are some
people normally when I was training you
could basically plat 1 over the [ __ ]
over time and come up with almost a
straight line of deterioration of renal
function it now looks like pen kid if
you put that into an equation a
progressive CKD that if the pent kid in
that setting is elevated that curve or
progression to renal replacement therapy
and dialysis is steeper we don't even
know exactly why or what the stimulus
for Penn kid is in this setting but it's
something that obviously in the future
we're going to look at very carefully
especially in diseases like diabetes and
other comorbidities that go along with
CKD to see what we can come up with hey
thank you so very much I do appreciate
that you is there a role for Penn kid in
cdk diagnosis monitoring and treatment
here it looks like we have that question
here well I think that's I think that's
probably the one that Bobby that I just
that I just answered so let's go to a
different one thank you thank you so
very much I appreciate that doctor here
and we do have this question um once the
patient comes in and is elevated seeing
our ease and the CR use our normal here
so and apologize here what if the
patient comes in and the pancake is
elevated and the CR ease is normal would
you just consider to be at risk for a TI
or not at risk already based on the
elevations well and I showed this in a
couple slides but for my way of looking
at things and the data suggests that if
your pen kid is high and especially I
think if you see the peg kid rising in a
couple hours remember it comes a couple
days before the credit they are a very
high risk for developing
kidney injury someday you may hit you
made based the diagnosis of kinsey
kidney injury on penn kid it's just so
happen creatinine is a gold standard of
sorts you know in the old days the gold
standard for an mi was ck-mb and then we
found out that early elevations of
troponin was more or more sensitive and
specific so i think that the time will
tell but right now a hype NK kid and the
krati normal tells you beware and
there's certain things when I beware
like for heart failure I hold I would
hold off on the ACE inhibitor I would
make sure they don't get me renal toxic
antibiotics I would monitor fluid and
diuretics very very carefully it thank
you so very much and dr. happen how does
10 kid compared with mr. check sure I
think never check the big difference I
mean is you know never checks a urine
marker pen kids in the blood and I think
most of it focus today has really been
looking at paint kid to just augment our
current standards since you know network
check is not yet although it's out there
not yet the current standard it really
hasn't been examined although I am sure
in the near future there will be
comparative data between the tubes and
whenever you compare the data one could
be better than the other sometimes
there's even a role for both blood and
inner Parker so we'll have to see thank
you so very much other tenken assay is
ready to come in routine clinical
practice we took you I might think I'd
lost can you repeat that please oh ya
got nothin on problem at all doctor yeah
are there pen kid assay is ready to come
in in routine clinical practice well as
a matter of fact you can already get
painted
over in Europe for clinical use and
since and i'll tell you i've talked to
these people doing some of these studies
i showed you the Albee asif frog study
here they've seen it they've seen the
results of their study these guys are
starting to order this clinically over
there now right now it's a research tool
in the united states for a while as
things are being prepared and there will
be two major labs very soon announce
that you will be able to order this from
for research purposes only to start with
but i expect in the not-too-distant
future this will be a clinically
available test thank you so very much
and do you use pen kid with pro
considering in monitoring your surface
patience and your can you repeat the
question Bobby there oh yes I do
apologize on that yes and you use a pen
kid with your facilitation in monitoring
your septic patients well again it's not
available yet in the United States but I
think what I've been hearing from the
people now using this in sepsis over in
Europe where the kits are available is
that you should use this to monitor
patients and I showed you in dr. de soma
study and sepsis in the ED that a high
tank kid level needs to be followed up
because if it goes low they're safe if
it's not they do they do poorly the same
token if a low pancake gets worse during
hospitalization they do poorly and this
is just in my sweet spot as a biomarker
person I want a biomarker that not only
gives me risk but it allows me to chance
to see a change based on what i do to
the patient because i know i'll try
sometimes it doesn't work you know what
I'm going to try something else and then
something else in something else i'm not
going to give up its grilling steak for
me i have more opportunities
no thank you so very much and is in more
data coming available on the pension
test in the US population oh yes that's
a great question and there are numerous
studies that are just being finished up
and some are in line to be published
quite soon so even though we've had over
20,000 people study you're going to see
more and more us datasets being
published in within the year of 2017 for
sure thank you so very much socket and
how does it perform this CD k as
co-morbidity and then a follow-up
question is what is the status of the
FDA trials and clearance for commercial
sale in the US well I think that again
talking about the CKD I think it
definitely is going to is you know it's
a kidney marker you saw the fantastic
correlation with creatinine the inverse
correlation with GF r and the fat that
if it's still high in CKD can make it
make there be a steeper slope to
progression for dialysis I am not privy
to the FDA strategy yet but I know there
have been talks and there have been
plans for you know 510 K I don't know
where all that sits yet but I know I
know the owners of this test are hopeful
that in the not-too-distant future we
will have this clinically available it
just so very much and do you see
integrating this test into clinical
practice well how do you see this well I
first of all if I didn't see that I
could integrate this in clinical
practice I absolutely would not talk
about this test and because I get asked
to talk about a lot of things I need to
talk about do research with and work
with biomarkers that I will immediately
integrate so how would i integrate this
well
of all right now anybody comes to the
emergency room with acute heart failure
I get a BNP troponin when st2 and
procalcitonin and that gives me a
measure of wall stress the propensity
for fibrosis mari myocardial necrosis
and also the possibility of presence of
a concomitant bacterial infection what I
don't have is something to tell me which
of those patients which third of those
patients are going to get kidney injury
a cranny probably will not tell me that
because it's an older biomarker it's
telling us more in the past three days
than what we're seeing in the ED so if
you have a hit of the pen kid let's say
you have a high pain kid in that city
and you have a high B and P suggesting a
lot of volume you're going to need to
give diuretics and your troponin ties so
that high volume is stretching the heart
and doing damage and your pen kids hi
you're going to be very careful knowing
you have to give a lot of diuretic to
take care of anything else that could
hurt the kidney so I would not under any
circumstance keep the ACE inhibitor
going for a day or two while I do this I
wouldn't go run to get any contrast CT
scans and if I thought that patient
needed a cardiac catheterization because
maybe as an mi causing it I would be
loath to do this unless that were an
absolute emergency in the setting of a
hypen kid when you have to give contrast
agents this could really shut the
kidneys down now you can make the same
case in sepsis you know how important it
is because in sepsis in the emergency
room gosh with fifty percent mortality
if you do get a ki and and you're
thinking more about contrast you're
thinking more about pouring a lot of
different anti
addicts you're not quite sure they're
hypotensive do you give vasopressors do
you get fluid I'm putting a swan-ganz
and I'm lining that guy up I'm going to
be carried careful my fluids nobody's
putting in contrast unless it's
absolutely necessary and I'm going to
treat them vigorously and then again
finally the same at least in my spectrum
acute myocardial infarction I showed you
the data it's very prognostic if there's
a high risk for kidney injury and it's
not a STEMI do you need to take them to
the cath lab that day I mean really you
know and I wouldn't I would tune things
up try to get that pen kid down see what
happens the Kratt in and move ahead
cautiously so I answer that question
enthusiastically by saying I will
integrate this test into my practice the
day that I get it and I'm jealous of my
friends in Europe that are already doing
this thank you so very much doctor and
give any conference on the end gallop
effectiveness as a biomarker well you
know ankle is with both blood in the
urine and there's you know there's there
we just published and you can go to the
jack article I let a multicenter trial
in heart failure it was an gal blood and
urine and the results were not great in
part because creatinine sometimes
actually rises in heart failure without
kidney injury just from a ferent an
affair and effects on the kidding but in
that study then gal while it was
predictive wasn't any better they
created so there was a potential sweet
spot of a negative predictive value of a
low-end gal in the setting of people CKD
and that needs to be explored explored
more I think the problem and what
confused people is that they tried to
bring this marker out in in patients
with sepsis and there it's probably not
as good because of the
inflammation that is also present and so
I know I know a couple companies have
sort of stopped looking at the end gal I
know that by a porta which is a good
company is sort of taking up the mantle
for both the blood in the urine and and
we'll have to see but right now it's not
quite given us what we've wanted in a
biomarker and very few people will have
the opportunity to try this over the
years are still using this thinking and
is there a difference with the pro and
Penn kid no no pink kid is really the
other name for the pro kefflin which is
the surrogate marker so pen kate is sort
of the branding for the pro and kefflin
which is the pro neurohormonal marker
for the ink Evelyn which is Mark Lee
expressed throughout the kidney but is
very difficult to measure this is a
stable surrogate but it but it's got the
half-life short enough that you could
see changes quickly when there's changes
in the condition thank you so very much
and have you looked at Penn kid in every
m species besides she knows uh yes I
think I don't have all that data and I
haven't personally but there are many
many animal models of kidney injury go I
mean going way back to even and kefflin
and opioid receptors I showed on the
first slide many many animal models were
you really saw in kefflin expressed by
kidney versus by receptors in the kidney
and a little less in the heart so I
think all all data human data needs to
obviously be first shown in some animal
models and I don't know all the models
offhand but I've know I've know the
results have been consistent suggesting
that there's a need within kefflin
associated with the need for the kidney
to operate and perform normally and
excrete what it needs to excrete so i
think i think that data is there for the
looking thank you so very much and how
is pen can measures in your facility
well so there's a chemiluminescence
assay but again we are not measuring yet
in my facility there are kits available
in Europe that are being used and I
suspect I'm not sure what they're going
to do with the FDA here i am sure
eventually at some point this will be
made available so that it could be
easily used is in a live a essay or even
potentially as a point-of-care essay
thank you very much you kinda dilute it
to this boat when it is going to be
available in the US well again I can't I
don't really have a crystal ball on this
one i I don't know I think I think they
have been in there have been discussions
with the FDA and that's sort of all we
can say right now and again I'm not in
the position to really be privy privy to
that I do know that very soon it will be
available for research and if I did have
to look at my crystal ball if you asked
me five more times I think probably hear
you know the FDA is created problems for
all sorts of biomarkers and biomarker
company so that year has to have a great
deal of variation on it at this point
thank you so very much so we have a
revised question here if patients with
cdk how accurately does it predict and
Aki well I think that remember i also
said at the end that you don't use a
biomarker by itself so if you have
somebody with CKD come in and we see
this all the time and they come in with
acute heart failure we're worried
whether that creatinine is going to bump
in that setting a high pen kit and a
rising pen kid in the first few hours
would make me very suspicious that aki
is happening and can you use intended
for tailoring amino gloss I distance
well uh gosh I don't know the answer to
that yet it's a think this will be
potentially one of the studies that will
be done there is precedent in certainly
using biomarkers to guide antibiotics
for instance uh in in Switzerland the
pro ha studies led by bet Mueller has
suggested using procalcitonin to guide
how long you give antibiotics works well
you can cut it by a third how much
antibiotics you use with the peak and
trough of the mean of glycosides and
you're worried about those you know I
think it's a little bit of a stretch at
this time but I think a good a good
solid research study would be beautiful
beautiful in this area thank you so very
much and doctor thank you again for
going through all these questions with
us today do you have any final comments
for today mom Ian well I think my final
comment would be first of all thank you
all very much for taking time I know you
all everybody's so busy these days and
and I really appreciate it and and I'm
you know I I'm really excited about this
biomarker you know I live in the kidney
field as the kidney relates to the heart
and the fact that this pen kid is sort
of given I think I think not only
expression of what's going on the kidney
but the interaction the acute and cardio
renal interaction is going to be super
important this is still a space that is
you know low-hanging fruit of an unmet
need I need good biomarkers this looks
to be lining up is really the top of the
heap for ones that we should go after
and I'm very excited and you know I
think we're actually having stay tuned
and we're going to have another webinar
november i can't i can't remember the
exact date i can look it up here while I
look but I think we're going to buy that
time we're going to even have new data
and also will know which labs are
running
so if your friends or colleagues didn't
come to this one please come to the next
one it won't all be me it'll be it'll be
some kidney people and some ed people
and it should be it should be fantastic
i believe it's now in november nine so
be updated from here and if you want to
come again we'll have some more data you
get different perspective i'll just be
one of three speakers but otherwise tell
your colleagues if you're excited about
this tell your colleagues the way we get
biomarkers going is to get people
excited and it doesn't matter whether
your kitty doctor a heart doctor a lab
dr. or industry that's trying to make
therapeutic drugs to affect the kidney
get excited about this and let's let
people circle the wagons around and
extend them out and expand the knowledge
base that we have thank you again dr.
nasal for your outstanding presentation
and this I do want to remind the
audience once again for that November
the ninth date or dr. nasal will be here
with this whole faculty with an upcoming
webinar as well well I'd also like then
definitely here still dr. I'm fine yeah
and I would all like to thank the
audience as well again for your
outstanding questions and sign 8x4 also
making this webcast possible as well
again that november the ninth state
please mark it on your calendars and
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through april 2017
you'll receive an email from lab roots
alerting me where this Web cast will be
available for replay and then we're
going to invite you to for that
announcement to your colleagues who have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye